foreign
[Music]
that's good water
uh hope everyone is doing well
it's a new year
could have fooled me
we got hello homebody Miss Wicked Wolf
adrenaline oh hey Meg good to see you
hey Carolyn Adrian
of Alliance which I probably butchered
hey Pirates
Ben
but it's good to see folks here
there we go
that feels better
love the lace thank you I like this top
I'm rather fond of it
huh
avulians four beats okay
I'll forget next time I say it out loud
I'm just warning you right now and
that's not bitterness that's just
my brain
do I use an ale file rarely generally
only if after I've clipped my nails
um
if like I've gotten it if I've got like
a little bit that's ended up pointing
away I didn't like
excuse me
I hope folks are doing well
um reminder that
um
while I will try and keep up with the
chat the only thing that guarantees that
I will see and respond to your comment
is the super chats but that will also
get you a heart of appreciation from me
uh
did I watch the ball drop I did I did
stayed up with my kiddo to watch that
hmm
uh I hope the new year treated everyone
well well I hope New Year the event was
nice for everyone and I hope that the
new year so far has treated you as well
as it can given you know
the usual state of the world
ah
keeping up with the chat is hard thing
for me because I don't always notice it
I'll I'll notice it but like what'll
happen for me and it's
I mean it's just a very me thing is I'll
I'll get into a topic maybe it's an
answer to a question maybe it's just
something that I um
I started thinking Yvonne decided to
start talking about I'll just ramble on
a topic for like five minutes and
realize oh I've missed a lot of chat
activity
so that's that's more my issue
rather than forgetting that it's there
it's just uh losing track of
my own mouth I suppose starting classes
next week anatomy and physiology and
history of rock and roll yeah rock and
roll wow
I don't know what that was but enjoy it
I'm eating raspberries
I can't do the rock scream well no
that's not true I I used to be able to
I'm out of practice though and I had to
work up that I was during the brief
period when I was
into the Jesus Christ Superstar
soundtrack
I could do it then
it's been a bit though
History of Rock and Roll was honestly
something I added because I needed
enough credits to get financial aid hey
sounds like a winner to me
also because I love rock and roll there
it is
there it is
am I open to being sent writing or is my
schedule too busy I um
uh I can't I I'm yeah I am
embarrassingly far behind on getting to
the stuff that I have been paid to take
a look at I absolutely do not have the
time to look at people's writing
um
just to give feedback I I just I don't I
don't have enough time for the stuff
that I I'm already supposed to be doing
are we honestly Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania yeah I expect I will
oh I need to react to that new trailer
and I completely forgot to do that I had
to do that once we finish up here
my 14 uh year old niece came out as
non-binary trans masculine that's
wonderful do they still want to be
referred to as a niece uh or would they
now prefer a nephew
unfortunately I don't think
I don't think there's a gender gender
neutral
term for niece or nephew
which is unfortunate
or if there is I don't know it
what is my opinion of My Chemical
Romance as a band I don't really have
one I don't know that much of their
stuff the few bits of their stuff I know
like it's fine it's enjoyable enough
um that's kind of it
interesting story I was browsing through
YouTube and found a vid talking about
Castlevania curse of Darkness the game
where Hector and Isaac
came from when I learned they did Hector
bad really
I'm assuming when you say they did
Hector bagamin in the uh the Castlevania
uh series oh interesting
favorite rock and roll artists the
stones Janis Joplin Fleetwood Mac Stevie
Nicks solid picks very nice
nibbling is the gender-neutral turn for
niece slash nephew
I think I have heard that before
it's been a while since I've heard it
though
and I and I don't have cost to use it
myself it's one of those things that I
have heard it now that I now that you
remind me but it's never gotten
reinforced because I have neither well I
have I do not have nieces nephews or
niblings
um I did by marriage a bit back but I'm
divorced but even if I were to refer to
them as niece or nephew
um you know they're not non-binary so
got a piece of hair on the back yeah
this one this one stray freaking strand
this has been annoying me all day
actually
not entirely sure what the hell the deal
with that was
ah
I think I was misremembering nibbling as
nubbing
nothing
almost feels like a cutesy term for
something
not safe for work
if two gender fluid people are dating
are they a gay couple or do they need to
synchronize their genders at a given
time asking for the sake of my partner
and I I would just say that you're a
queer couple and leave it at that
because then you don't have to worry
about splitting hairs depending on where
uh one or the other of you is on any
given day
I mean the thing about being gender
fluid and I have made this uh
observation in the past
because I'm gender fluid
no matter what your gender identity is
if you think I'm attracted
attractive
if you are attracted to me
you're at least a little bit gay
my favorite band is rush if I had to
pick one oh cool
do I like classical yeah for the most
part
favorite band is Spanish love songs I
have never heard of that
is there a gender-neutral term for
girlfriend boyfriend sort of
I mean there's partner although at least
for me I can't speak for everyone else
um the thing about the term partner is
in my mind that is a more committed
relationship than just boyfriend
girlfriend
so I don't know if there's something of
like comparable
like dating but not necessarily super
serious uh in gender neutral
I don't know that's that's my headspace
though other people might not feel the
same about partner that I do
favorite Fleetwood Mac song ah
it's hard to beat chains
that entire album the rumors is
crazy good
my girlfriend started watching
Castlevania for the first time her
review of season was Alucard is hot
I mean
sure if you're into that
um
he doesn't really do it for me
like appearance wise he's fine he's just
he's too stoic
I think for my taste
did I see the trailer for Renfield I did
and it's the kind of trailer where I
watch that
excuse me
and I'm like okay
either we just saw every good part of
this entire movie
or
this is going to be amazing no middle
ground
nibbling makes them sound like a biter
which my niece used to be so fair hey
there you go
had to gently educate a dear friend that
when someone has transitioned you don't
go back to the old pronoun dead name
when talking about them before
transition she thanked me and promised
to remember and that's the best reaction
that you can hope for and that is
something that like
people who aren't used to interacting
with or talking about or too
um trans or queer people might not get
because like
they might Intuit okay but I'm referring
to back then
but at the same time like
you know it's one of those things where
if you stop and think about it more like
okay but
like if somebody got married and took on
their spouse's name you you don't go out
of your way to refer to them by their
maiden name if you talk about before
they were married
generally anyways I don't know
John vinyls
thank you very much
if Arcane ever makes it to Broadway you
should play Jace oh Jace
oh he's the boring one
he's the guy who's just so determined to
do the right thing like he's still on
the scale of characters like that he's
actually still quite interesting but
like in terms of something to play
sink my teeth into
oh no not my uh
not my first pick
give me silco
[Music]
that
that I could have fun with
and John vinyl's coming in again right
after also whoever leaked for the future
online needs to be spanked
I think I'm missing something there I'm
not sure what that is
uh let's see
Hey sir Jedi Sentinel good to see you
uh
I'm trying to figure out where I was
in the chat
uh love Abba body love Dancing Queen
Dancing Queen is fun that is one of
those songs that like I'm kind of antsy
until the chorus kicks in
do I think Yasmine Finney is upset she's
in the main comparison I have absolutely
no idea and I'm not gonna speculate on
someone's
personal mood
I don't know enough about her and even
begin to guess at that
I have not seen Guillermo del Toros
Pinocchio I have not had the time
having the Beatles and you're just
comparing classic rock notes all right
that works
uh I technically don't have a main name
but I don't really use the longer name
that makes a part of my legal hyphenated
name oh
that got complicated
whatever happened to CLA to class would
you open yourself to reviewing it to
re-reviewing it well I'd have to review
it once before I could re-review it I
just never got around to it it didn't
strike me as that interesting and
honestly
none of the Doctor Who spin-offs have
done much for me I don't have a lot of
um
this is part of why I'm I kind of like
tilt my head and like
really that some people are like really
excited at the idea of more Doctor Who
spin-offs because
I didn't like any of them that much
the one that that like and like I'm not
saying any of them were bad but like I
think of okay so you had Sarah Jane
Adventures which was Doctor Who for an
even younger age group fine cool I am
A-Okay without existing
I didn't connect with it I was too old
for it just flatly in terms of the tone
and everything it was going for
so like that didn't do much for me
Torchwood God
Torchwood was a freaking mess it was and
children of birth is great but that's
one series out of four that was
genuinely good and the rest like had
moments that were good but on the whole
was like
so like the enthusiasm for
um
for spin-offs in general I just I I'm
not gonna say I don't get it I guess I
get it I get it in the sense that you
obviously got more out of these things
than I did but I don't share it
anyone like Queen oh Queen's great
Love Queen Queen's fantastic
does anyone think of spanking as a
punishment anymore
um
uh
depends if we're talking about children
moving on
newest Owl House episode was leaked for
the future
oh
okay I hadn't heard about that
so that that went over my head
so that's why I didn't follow that
uh basically if uh Hector from uh the
castlemanian darkness was in the show he
would have beat the crap out of Carmella
if he thought for an instant she would
betray Dracula also he was a voice by
Crispin Freeman I know that name but I'm
drawing a blank
director Scarlett that's an interesting
name for the future is the next Owl
House episode it's definitely worth a
watch and has the best lgbtqia
representation I've Seen On TV so okay
wait
is it actually available right now or
was it just leaked because if I'm gonna
have to like dig through torrent sites
I'm not gonna do that
have I seen the movie Megan yet I have
not it's not high on my priority list
I've heard good things but it's like not
a genre I'm super into and I'm behind on
a lot of work
like that's the thing I'm not rushing
out to the theater right now because I'm
behind I'm starting out this year behind
so
whatever happened to class is my
favorite song from Chicago oh
interesting not mine but yeah I'm on
that one can work
ah let's see
what are my thoughts on people leaking
episodes of TV shows before they get a
chance to air
um
I don't really have one
like
I was gonna say I guess it depends on
who they are how they got it and why
they did it but honestly I'm never gonna
do the research to dig into that 99
times out of 100 my general reaction is
just
okay
like I don't I don't care enough about
um
corporate interests to
be offended by it like I can I can
be disappointed on behalf of the
creators of a thing
but like ultimately you know the air
date and the rest of it is
that's a corporate level decision so
I'm I am if the creators are frustrated
by it I feel sorry for them that's about
all I've got
[Music]
one of my friends changed his name to
his husbands when they got married makes
me think a woman's surname at Birth is
her maiden name so what do you call it
for a man
um
his princely name
not sure John vinyls coming back in much
appreciated for all the support uh if
there was ever a staged version of dead
end paranormal Park Centaur World
Wendell and wild keep on the age of
Wonder B's Hilda and or the Owl House
who would you most love to play in those
musicals boy you went big
um
okay
uh dead end paranormal Park
um
actually
it's a side character but it's it I
don't think I'm a fit for most of the
main cast on that but I think I could
have fun playing uh Harmony
who is uh one of the villains from
season one
Centaur world
um
okay setting aside like the
impossibility of this because like
Centaur world is not stageable but like
Becky apples
give me Becky
she's the best Wendell and wild I
haven't seen
uh kippo and the age of Wonder beasts
um
I could have a lot of fun playing
Scarlet Mane
Hilda oh the woodsmen
oh it'd be so much fun
Owl House
I think Hootie
I have too much fun just voicing hoodie
okay loose it's time for you to go to
school and fill your head with
delicious knowledge
I like torture but I prefer who Captain
Jack the torch with Captain Jack yeah I
mean that's part of it that's not the
only thing I don't like about Torchwood
but that is part of it
they need to get big finish writers in
for spin-offs people say that I don't
think I agree
I don't
I don't ever want to see them drain the
big finish talent pool
to fill the show like it's a different
medium they're doing different things
let them do their thing leave it alone
like if any of them like want to put
their hand up and go hey I'll do it if
you want me sure give them a shot but
[Music]
255 A.D thank you for the Super Chat
should you apologize for using a trans
person's dead name before they came out
I've seen a few people do that but
wouldn't anything else be disrespecting
the identity they had at the time
all right I'm gonna see if I can follow
this question
um
so unless I'm misunderstanding the first
part of your question
if they were using a person's dead name
before that before that trans person
came out
I don't know necessarily what there
would be to apologize for because you
didn't know
I mean that's not to say that there's
anything wrong with
um with saying oh sorry that you know
that wasn't who you were but I mean
depending on the trans person and their
own nature they might not have known
either for a while
I
as long as you're using the correct name
from the point at which you find out
what that is
um if on a personal level it like
feels necessary to go I'm sorry I used
to call you something out I mean I guess
there's nothing wrong with saying that
it's the question on its premise doesn't
make sense to me because like
they they wouldn't have known anything
other than a person's dead name before
that person came out to them so
what are you apologizing for
I I guess it's like apologizing for the
I'm sorry that you were in the closet
I'm sorry you went through that but like
funneling it through I'm uh the idea of
I'm sorry I used your dead name
I don't know
I don't know I'm kind of lost in this
question
since we're already talking rock bands
thoughts on The Kinks I don't know too
much of their stuff
excuse me
uh who isn't behind this year hmm
yeah well
Fat Bottom Girls you make the rock and
roll go round
That's a classic
uh who is a character that you initially
hated but find yourself liking loving by
the end well Donna Noble's the big one I
did not like her at all in Runaway Bride
at
oh
and oddly I'm warming up to Franklin on
Babylon 5 and he was in the hole real
bad for a bit there
but
Donna's pretty much the big one
must be late have you seen the
quantumania trailer I haven't I need to
do a reaction after we finish up here
also if you uh want to know what Isaac
in cursive Darkness uh uh just look him
up draw your own conclusion all right
I'll try and remember to do that later
and Rice's Mayfair which is on AMC plus
was interesting oh is that started
I think I'd heard that was going to be a
thing
uh Grace was a character I didn't really
like in the beginning but by the end of
Farscape he was my favorite well yes but
he's like
I'm not sure that quite works or at
least the way that I think of that
question I think that's kind of against
the spirit of the question because in my
mind Grace was not a character you're
supposed to like he was one he was the
main villain initially you're not
supposed to like him whereas like I
think about characters like Franklin and
Babylon 5 or Donna Noble
and I don't think you were intended to
dislike them but I did
for a bit
have I seen and or not only have I seen
Endor I did like a 30 minute video
talking about how awesome it is
can I ask why you don't like the visual
style and comedy of anime
um you can ask I don't have a firm
answer for you
just doesn't
resonate with me
I I it's it's one of the hard things
um especially trying to dissect comedy
like because sometimes sometimes you can
pull apart like okay well you failed in
the delivery of that joke like here's
why the joke fell apart because you you
didn't set it up right or the punchline
was wrong or the Cadence of the delivery
was wrong like sometimes comedy falls
down on the technicals and sometimes you
just go I don't think that's funny
and how do you
how do you explain it beyond that
I don't think it's funny and
a lot of the visual comedies and Anime I
they they yank me out of it I think is
the big thing
they do that thing where they'll they'll
stop dead and the animation goes Super
simplified and super exaggerated faces
and like you know the sweat drop or the
tear streams or whatever like it pulls
me out of the story is what it does
it it
feels like because it's a borderline
fourth wall break
and
not all stories work with that at least
I don't feel
seeing as it was written by Terry Jones
uh can you do jareth's big monologue but
in the voice of Brian's mom
all right hold on
Sarah beware I have been generous up
until now
everything I've done is generous you
asked the baby be taken I took him
you coward before me I was frightening
I've reordered time I've turned the
world upside down and I've done it all
for you
I am exhausted from living up to your
expectations of me isn't that generous
put that on the list of things I didn't
think I'd be doing with my evening
oh boy
I find it interesting that Jim know
wrote my least favorite Cyberman story
cyber woman and my favorite Cybermen
story Haunting of villa Dia daddy oh
that is interesting
ah
let's see
foreign
ly one of the things I'm excited about
for the new era Scott Hancock a big
finish writer primarily the producer of
the warm Master Series is the script
editor ooh I didn't know that that is
interesting actually
ooh John vinyls back again thank you my
friend
would love to hear what your favorite
roles you've ever played in theater and
what are your all-time favorite theater
Productions which you've started uh it's
the same answer
for both the part that
I was so proud of my work in
and I really felt like oh God yes about
and I also think was the best play I was
in was a Few Good Men
and I played
um Lieutenant
um Lieutenant Junior grade Daniel Caffey
which if you've seen the movie is Tom
Cruise's part
he talks a lot he has over 500 lines in
that play
I had a lot to memorize
but it was really good and I was really
and that's the only time I've gotten the
lead I've never had the lead in a in a
full play before
I don't even think I've had a lead in
one act before I've always had
supporting roles I've had character
Parts which I enjoy doing don't get me
wrong but ah that was so rewarding I
think the the second is not too far
behind that is
confusingly in terms of remembering the
titles 12 Angry Men in which I played
juror number
seven
in that one
that was also a good show and I was
proud of what I did there
[Music]
do you
do what's your favorite character uh uh
has sorry let me try this again
has your favorite character in a show
ever been someone who was only in it for
an episode the captain was that for me
in Castlevania the captain is great
um that I I can't think of an instance
off the top my head
that might have happened at some point
that's a good example though I like it I
like it
my favorite Babylon 5 character is
Ivanova londo's a close second solid
picks
uh
let's see I'm trying to catch up I'm
behind on the chat like I'm behind on
everything else okay so this is sort of
circling back to the to the question I I
think I didn't understand about dead
Navy no I'm just saying that I've seen
some Progressive video people say I'm
sorry I called you a man and used your
dead name before you came out and I'm
like no that was right
um oh okay so all right there's some
context there you didn't give me because
if you're talking about people in videos
what I would assume there is what they
are apologizing for is that is the fact
that a video exists online in which this
person is referred to by their dead name
and and wrong pronouns
so like at least that would be my read
on somebody putting out a video to that
effect
um so my read on that would not be
apologizing for
um having said it wrong at the time
because like I said no they wouldn't
have known at the time but they might be
apologizing for the existence of a video
that may well still be up
that's that would be my read on that
as the new Cameron avatar on your watch
list list is that geeky enough I do
actually want to try and get to it
before it leaves theaters because like
um if I'm going to watch it I feel like
I kind of owe the movie
to watch it in a theater that's kind of
how it's meant to be seen and to the
extent that I liked the first one it was
the immersion of the experience
excuse me of the experience but it's a
three-hour damn movie
have you any vid have you seen any
visibility channels history Buffs and if
not he does vids talking about
historically based movies and how they
adapt real world history example
Tombstone or Zulu I have not watched
that
and I suspect it's a topic I'd probably
get
uh board with
um just because like
unless I had a specific it would be
something I got bored with if I watched
a lot of maybe if I went through it and
looked for specific movies that I was
curious about the real history on maybe
but it's not something I could just
visit as a general topic a lot
how much to do a burlesque act as
Brian's mom I'd have to find a show
where it would fit the theming of uh of
what was going on for uh for that to
even be an option and theoretically the
venue would pay me so
uh
[Music]
uh
where are we
uh how do I clarify who a trans person
is without dead naming them
um
well
so this is
this is one of those things where I feel
like
um there was going to be
some
differences depending on the specific
nature of the person you're talking to
and how
how respectful they will be
so what I mean by that is
there are sometimes
um that frankly
the easiest way for you to talk about a
trans person is someone who does not yet
know that that person has transitioned
is to go okay you knew them as bit
they're now bit and if the person you're
talking with is someone who's going to
respect the new name new pronouns and
everything
I don't think it's inherently harmful to
say that once just so that they're up to
speed where you need to be careful is if
they're the kind of person who's going
to use well you said it why can't I say
it
um or anything like that
um and if it's anything like that or if
there's someone who you think might jump
down your throat for having brought up a
dead name uh even though they didn't
know prior to that point then finding
some
thing to it so like
random example Elliot page
if you know that this person knows some
of his earlier work you can go Elliot
page you know he starred in Juno that
was before he transitioned but that's
who I'm talking about if you can find a
point of reference that you know for
certain they'll get
go with that
um but again like I said I don't think
it's the end of the world to say the
dead name once if it's someone you can
trust to not be to not use that as an
excuse to be a dick
um just to just to smooth out things uh
also ideally not in the earshot of
others because then people hearing you
use someone's dead name with no context
as to why you're doing it that can cause
an issue like it's just yeah it's a
whole thing
I always got supporting roles in
Theatrical Productions myself yeah
and I don't mind it I had a lot of great
roles
uh Was A Few Good Men the one with Ryan
and Paul it was carowind that is indeed
the one that that was
uh they were they were all really good
to work with that was that was a lot of
fun
uh let's see
uh do you like the song How Will I Know
by Whitney Houston don't even know that
one off the top of my head so I'm gonna
go with indifferent
I'm also an actor I played the lead
twice once I played Orlando and as you
like it that's a good show and one says
suitable isn't a Funny Thing Happened on
the Way to the Forum that's a good one I
I was in a funny thing happened on the
way before him in high school
and I cannot remember the character's
name anymore but I played the old man uh
the one who's walking around the Seven
Hills
of Rome
and you know it being a farce you had to
do the old man voice
and so all my lines were like this
yeah that was exhausting
ah
[Music]
oh Bookworm I had been talking about A
Few Good Men before I brought up 12
Angry Men and actually
um my friends Ryan and Paul were
involved in both
because 12 Angry Men Paul directed Ryan
was in as was I A Few Good Men my kiddos
mother directed and I was in him both
Ryan and my friends Ryan and Paul acted
in that so like I kind of mentioned at
the time
it's confusing because the names are
similar A Few Good Men 12 Angry Men
Too Many Men ain't that the state of the
world
oh dear someone's gonna clip that
uh a close friend of mine transitioned
to a woman haven't seen them in a long
time and every time I see their mother
uh he keeps telling me their child
transition and their name I think she
thinks I have a poor memory well either
that or she has a poor memory and she
keeps forgetting she's told you
ah any suggestions for cozy sci-fi
before I beside the Wayfarer series I
don't know
depends on what you fight like I
personally find the uh Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy pretty cozy another
a little dark at times
uh erroneous thank you nura that is that
was the character's name it's been a god
that was what that was senior year high
school was
that was over 22 years ago
it's easy
for me to forget
because
we didn't have the 20th anniversary
because what would have been my 20th
high school reunion
was 2020.
I wonder
what went
wrong
ah
Rowan don't tag me and tell me what's
going to be in a trailer I haven't seen
yet don't do that
come on
ah
see you Ben if I just stopped in
uh did you hear the good news the doctor
reverse regenerated and the tenth doctor
is back
um
generation Productions I'm assuming
you're new here
I have multiple videos talking about the
fact that that happened
so we are yeah I am uh I'm aware
foreign
I'm talking about a YouTuber so I don't
know anything about the people I'm
correcting and it's inherently public ah
okay
so I'm a
assuming you're talking about correcting
in the comment section
okay well in that case
I would I personally from my view and
understand I do not speak for all trans
people
um
from my view
that would be okay because the dead name
was not introduced by you
it was introduced by the person in the
video
and if they appear to not be aware
referencing the dead name that they used
incorrectly and saying what they should
have been using instead does seem like
the best and clearest way to communicate
that
so from from where I sit I wouldn't
think that you did anything wrong by
mentioning it in in that context again
once
um but that's me am I familiar with the
YouTuber Mr Tardis yep I'm familiar
okay now I want to make a play or a
movie called Too Many Men
see now I've just gotten my head the uh
the thing from
what was it Adult Swim too many cooks
too many men
Too Many Men
ah
a re-watch power of the doctor I noticed
that Ace was flirting with graham I did
not catch that the first time viewing
was she
I'm afraid to check that now
uh John vinyls thank you once again I
suggested just for you because I'd
prefer silicone to be played by an
albino person
is silco albino
because like he doesn't he still has
dark hair doesn't he
and like I'm not saying that trying to
like be like oh um
technically or whatever
but now he's still got dark hair I don't
think
he is albino
um sorry give me a second here
come on
um
yeah I don't
okay so it looks like at one point
in an earlier design he was going to be
white haired which would have probably
indicated
um albino or at least made it a strong
possibility but they ultimately didn't
go with that I mean I wouldn't have a
problem with
um
with him being played by an albino
at all but you threw me off with that
one
um Victor being played by an actual uh
disabled person I agree
disabled transmit is Victor trans did I
miss that
wait a minute
wait a minute what
hold on now
um
sorry give me a second
all right it looks like
uh
okay so it looks like Victor as a trans
man is a popular headcanon which I'm not
gonna contradict
totally down for that but he is
absolutely disabled regardless so at the
very least that disabled actor should be
playing Victor yeah anyways
um I'm sorry I got hung up on that but
you got to watch me Google things ain't
that exciting
[Laughter]
uh all right
first thing I watch on my Paramount Plus
account was Rugrats interesting picked
uh venga boys are back in town thank you
for the Super Chat remember you're a
Womble
okay
I'll try to do that
uh
uh who are some of those character
actors you always pop for when they show
up in something the that's that's a
difficult question to answer outside of
the context of them showing up because
kind of the nature of a lot of character
actors is you don't always think about
them until they show up then you're like
oh that one and so trying to be like oh
wait let me think it's it ah I at least
with my brain draws a bat and draws a
blank
uh
I was also attempting to cast you as the
collector in the Owl House musical and
as durpleton or stabby in the stage
version of Centaur world see stabby
needs to be reserved for my kiddo
because that's that's her favorite
character she adores stabby
ah
high voltage
let's see am I the only one who thinks
RTD plays it too safe with all the
doctors costumes like 14's costume seems
more like something a hipster would wear
I'm assuming you mean 15 because
officially tenant coming back is 14.
um like I need to kind of see it in
action you know and there were details
about it that I've missed from the per
the production images that came out like
the fact that there's like um a sash on
it the type which makes the coat look
like a borderline bathrobe which is
interesting
um I'm not I'm not going to ask on here
but if you stream on your Vera wild
channel is that the place to ask about
not safe or Worse questions or questions
related to the topics of that channel
um
Channel
all right here's
here's what I'll say to that uh Jamie
you can ask them here
you may get a slightly
softened answer
but I'm okay for you to ask
I might say
I I'm not comfortable answering that but
I'm not going to be offended if you ask
them here because like I said I don't I
don't remember the last time I streamed
on that channel
as
I'm kind of wondering specifically if I
should do a stream on that channel and
have it be
uh AMA NSFW
I don't know
hey
think on that
I watch adult swim I used to I don't
anymore uh you don't make a good bio
pick aside from Steve Irwin Andy Warhol
Andy Warhol I think has a few of those
uh okay freshly baked brownies back in
bile okay Meg thank you so much for
stopping in
Victor from Umbrella Academy no Jamie we
were talking about arcane
[Music]
um
yeah I have my own theory about 14 10th
return and 15 14th doctor did not want
to talk about how 13th were generated
into 1410 uh
is the close like I'm still curious to
see if we're gonna see uh an explanation
for that given that the meta explanation
was kind of
limp
uh I meant the 15th doctor by the way
numbering is off I figured that's
probably what you meant I did figure
that out
let's see here Bernard crippens was the
narrator for Wombles so there's the who
connection ah
Romano regenerated her clothes her
clothes so questions is uh as a Time
Lord gets more powerful they can
regenerate their clothes along with
their body we don't know if she did
though like those were those were gags
that could have involved time jumps and
giving her time to change an outfit as
well
so we don't know that for certain
Discord yes I need to I need to check
the Discord Channel reminder
um you do also get to ask me questions
on there it is guaranteed that I will
address them here holy crap we got a lot
okay I'm gonna try and burn through
these quick
um
Have you listened to the old gods of
Appalachia I have not I realize this is
speculation but why does the new boss at
Warner's uh want to set fire to things
like Looney Tunes and other cartoons
when these are clear winners over the
long term because he's not thinking long
term he's thinking short term he's
looking at a balance sheet and going
where are some expenses that aren't
generating a ton of Revenue in and of
themselves right now cool cut them
without thinking of the benefit of
access to a full library of people just
seeing more value of there being more
stuff available even if some of it is
less watched he's not taking a larger
holistic view he's taking an incredibly
narrow incredibly short-sighted View and
he's a [ __ ]
um do you like having uh I I mean like
in terms of how he's doing his job I
don't know how he is personally might be
a perfectly nice guy
I don't expect so but you know it's
possible uh do you like having a small
but dedicated fan base or would you be
happier if you could grow your audience
more that is tough like I I love my fan
base I adore my fan base but like if
only for the sake of my ego I would like
like here's the thing it's not that I
have to hit a certain number it's not
like Ma I have no value until I hit a
hundred thousand subscribers it's not
that but it is kind of a case of seeing
your growth completely Plateau which
I've done several times
um and it looks like it's about to
happen again that's disheartening
because I don't mind slow growth
flat growth takes the wind out of your
sails a little bit so I don't need to
hit a certain number but feeling like
nothing is is moving forward that that
can throw me off a bit
all right what have we got next have you
read or listened to Dungeon Crawler Carl
by Matt dinaman it's my current
Obsession and I feel like we have enough
in common you would love it too I have
not and I feel like I might have heard
of it but I don't really know anything
about it
I can't think of any more questions
right now I want you to know I want you
to know you are one of my favorite human
beings consuming your content brings me
great joy oh
thank you uh
uh why did you change the intro to The
Babylon 5 podcast as I thought the point
was that the unfamiliar one of you did
the opening which uh oh and then it's
the next question that got Okay so
it got updated because uh well first of
all we were into New Year and the old
um intro said the year is 2022 and it
wasn't anymore am we made the decision
to model the new intro after
um
uh
after the season three uh opening of the
show and that does feature a different
character giving it and also I'll point
out with the Farscape one Jesse did
initially I actually took over for the
uh for the intro the back half of that
again to coincide with a uh a difference
when the opening title uh changed for
the show itself so
um like we've done this before
which doctor would be most likely to
have a piercing why and where well I
mean the 13th Doctor did have a piercing
she had an ear piercing
um but other than that
[Applause]
[Music]
why is this in my head
ah
for some reason I want to say six would
have his nipples pierced
back that up but that's what's stuck in
my head so I went with it
ever heard of the silver John stories
they're pretty much rural paranormal
stories following a World War II veteran
named John who plays a guitar with
silver strings and encounters creatures
and then to and entities from the
Cthulhu Mythos as well as things like
Giants and witches in the Appalachian
Mountains I have not seems like there's
a decent amount of stuff set in
Appalachia which is a a decent setting
but no I've not heard of those
with witches werewolves and vampires
being so mainstream uh it's a base
series around with secret societies and
such have you ever wondered why more
people don't use knights in a modern
setting to similar effect I feel that's
an untapped setup for anyone to try and
play with but if you get to see it done
I think part of the problem is like
Knights
I feel a little too mundane and you'd
have to explain
you'd have to come up with a reason why
they are still behaving as Knights like
the organizations that Knights kind of
represented you know representation of
power be it you know the more mercenary
type or the protecting of state power
like we have equivalence to that so
like you'd have to you'd have to give it
a more fantastic event like actually
saying like the Knights of the Round
Table are still around which
unfortunately Sony did do when they did
the order 1886 and it was [ __ ] though
not because of the story idea
have you read any of savage Avengers it
features Conan the Barbarian being in
the Modern Marvel Universe ooh with him
treating the modern world like some big
Epic Fantasy Quest okay
it's not really Fish Out of Water story
so much as Conan actually refusing to
acknowledge too much of the modern world
and doing what he does best Quest needs
and maidens uh that's the setup I
actually like where the fantasy
characters popped in a modern setting
and they really just go about their
usual Style just in a new setting might
be simple but it always makes me smile I
actually love that as an idea
because
depending on the nature of the hero and
especially with somebody like Conan
who's like his entire deal is just
wandering from place to place and
dealing with whatever the world throws
at him yeah why would being in our world
be any different from his normal Mo say
oh okay this is how this play place
works all right I'm gonna do my thing
I kind of love it uh at least in
principle would you prefer it if Rose's
character in the 60th is written to have
a trans woman background uh to mirror
that of the woman who plays her or if
she's treated exactly the same as if she
were uh as if assist woman was cast I
don't have any inherent hopes one way or
the other I am very curious to see what
will happen I don't inherently think one
is better than the other and so I'm not
going in with a preference
why do you think it is that when Evan
Peters played Jeffrey Dahmer on Netflix
series people found it to be insensitive
but when David Tennant played uh Dennis
Nelson in a similar British show it was
met with critical claim is it just
because serial killers are more of a
touchy subject in the US or do you think
there's more to it I think there was a
difference of scope and scale most
people outside the UK didn't know about
um tenant playing that part
um whereas the Jeffrey Dahmer thing was
um you know it was in Netflix it was it
was a much bigger thing basically it was
big enough that more people noticed it
so more people who are going to take
offense to it were able to do so
um that's part of it one could probably
also make arguments about how um it
handled its material I know I don't know
a ton of I didn't look a ton into it but
I know that in the case of Dahmer there
were specifically some
surviving family members of the victims
who had issue with the way that it was
handled so that can add a lot of fuel to
the fire whereas if that wasn't the case
with David Tennant playing uh Dennis
Nelson then there's obviously a big
discrepancy there as well uh what would
your thoughts be if the BBC recast Jack
Harkness following all the John
Barrowman controversy just let the kids
the kid go
just let him just
just character
I I like Jack Harkness I do but he's not
the end-all be-all and a huge part of
what was enjoyable about him was the fun
that Berryman brought trying to bring in
somebody else to recreate it is gonna
feel like a like a second rate fill in
just let the just let the character be
retired do something else
ah
is it nobler in the mind just have the
things and arrows of Outrageous Fortune
or to take our arms against a sea of
troubles and by opposing end them
my answer to that my friend is to die to
sleep no more
and by asleep say we end the heartache
and the Thousand natural shocks that
flesh is heir to
the consummation devoutly to be wished
to die
to sleep sleep per chance to dream
we're in that dream of death friend
friend that sleep of death What Dreams
May Come
must give us pause
I almost
how you play the Doctor Who would you
choose as your companion feel free to
choose a specific actor or character
idea whatever is easier for you to think
of
um
I think
like honestly somebody like Evelyn
Smythe would be great if you know big
finish at all so somebody
um basically who is
uh in terms of the the physical
presentation of the character who seems
older and is not taking any of the
doctor's crap that would be it any
recommendations for obscure but awful TV
shows or movies not really I don't
indulge a lot in awful TV and movies if
I can help it
um and most things that I've seen that
are awful I wouldn't recommend in in
good conscience so have you seen Black
Adam is it in your Commission list I
have not and it is not uh uh I know I've
seen at least blue and purple what
colors have you tried out in your hair
so far I had a sort of a pinkish Violet
when I very first did it and and kind of
a turquoise that was a while back when I
first got it dyed
um have you tried ramoon
the soda with a marble in it I have
never heard of it so no we're almost
done with the Discord questions I
promise
remember
[Music]
hey
remember I told you Lily Simpson made a
10 hour video ripping Harry Potter apart
a number of other leftists the most
prominent of which being Sean have also
made videos uh taking the series to test
do you think part of the motivation
behind vids like this is progressives
wanting to be able to tell themselves
that Harry Potter was always terrible
actually because believing that makes it
easier to turn your back on something
that meant a lot to many of us I think
that's part of it I think enough other
thing I think another reason for it is
I think a lot of leftists have
frustration with people who otherwise
agree with the political with leftist
political views but are still partaking
of Harry Potter and who obviously have
chosen to either disregard or have
decided that whatever damage JK Rowling
has done that they that their love of
that series matters more to them than
what is happening
um and that I think for some of these
people they're trying so they're trying
to go at the heart of it's not even a
good thing to begin with because there's
clearly evidently a ton of people even
some who probably hold a lot of the
values of leftists who are saying please
stop buying anything that JK Rowling is
associated with who are still doing that
and I think there's a Hope on the part
of some of these folks to say look it's
it's not even that good not necessarily
because that and of itself will convince
people but because
becomes a matter of going look it's not
just that she's terrible the books
aren't even that good have you really
thought about the problems with them is
this the property you want to die on a
hill over
I think it's an attempt to to come at
the issue from a second front
I don't personally find it very helpful
especially because it kind of feeds into
the idea that
that bad people make bad art and that's
and that and the in the flip side of
that is good art is made by good people
and
I have no use for those Concepts because
neither of those have ever been true as
uh inherent facts
so I don't and also part of the thing is
like
part of my thing has been while I while
I personally have frustration with
people who continue to buy things like
Hogwarts Legacy God
[ __ ] damn it I do I still personally
do not begrudge people who still hold a
love for the stories the books the
movies and I don't want to tell them
that what they love is crap
I don't want to do that because as long
as they're not putting money to her
stuff anymore they just want to enjoy
the things they already have I don't
really want to take that from them I
have less issue overall when
a marginalized people are pointing out
the ways in which the Harry Potter
series has done their particular group
wrong so like I'd be absolutely up for
say
um a fat uh Advocate talking about the
fat phobia or any one of uh Jewish
descent talking about the anti-Semitism
or any person of color wants to talk
about the parallels between the
um
between the house elves and real world
slavery and how messed up that makes
everything like I and that's not to say
that no one else has a valid opinion but
for me personally I find more Merit in
that than just leftist going books bad
actually you know yeah I I feel like
that's too broad to be helpful anyways
I don't know that's just me people
disagree
so I don't think it's been spelled out
in any of the books I've made you read
but it's part of the culture lore that
minds are incapable of not acting
altruistically towards biological life
forms you're right it has not come up so
I did not know that some uh that does
answer that does make some sense though
especially given that some of them seem
to hold a fair amount of contempt for
biological life yet they uh they take
acts to protect it anyway somehow the
founders of the culture figured out how
to program the human bias for valuing
life into the progenitor minds and it
never went away like in the entire
series uh you never encounter a mind
that doesn't care about humans uh all
their internal disputes are about how to
help us how do you feel about that as a
Sci-Fi concept my Sapient AIS would
never do a Skynet because they're
incapable of hating humans I'm actually
very on board with that if only because
Skynet is freaking boring at this point
there are way more interesting Avenues
to examine than oh my gosh the AI
decided humans should die like we've
done it it's been done stop it stop stop
do something more interesting and this
is like I've enjoyed the culture books
I've enjoyed the minds a fair bit and
what you just laid out like that's a
much better idea a lot more story
possibilities than that
do you think Avatar would be closer to
real world colonialism
If instead of their world having stuff
we actually need we were just taking
Navi land to get some tribal luxury like
tobacco or chocolate
I listened to a podcast about that film
today presumably put out because of the
sequel and I think that's my main issue
with it the films uh the films Universe
humans need unobtainium to survive I
still can't believe he freaking called
it unobtainium my God
like I kind of like the first avatar
there's a lot of problems with it but I
kind of like that movie but I still
can't believe he wrote in a script and
an actor said and editors put together
film where they say unobtainium dear God
whereas real colonialism happened
because we were annoyed brown people who
wouldn't sell us certain stuff as cheap
as we'd like
um
well I
whether or not that's an issue I think
depends on whether or not you are
prepared to accept the movie on its own
terms or if you want to kind of get into
an issue of what you feel like it should
have been tackling and what I mean by
that is I think that
a lot of the colonial and white savior
aspects of Avatar which are very much
there are not what Cameron was
actively trying to do
I think he knew the story he wanted to
tell about this world about these people
and I think he landed on the story he
did because it just facilitated him
showing us so much of this world like
okay well we need it to be explained to
someone so we need a newcomer okay and
we're gonna need an antagonistic Force
well it'll be this I I feel like
the story that came out was not out of a
desire on Cameron's part to tell a
colonial or anti-colonial story but
rather just to come up with something
that would let him dwell in that world
for three hours and now for another
three and with that in mind
the unobtainium becomes a matter to kind
of
take the curse off it a little bit so
that it's not a one-to-one parallel
because if it is a one-to-one parallel
then the movie kinda owes the subject
better consideration than it gives it
like it's not like it ever sides with
the colonizing forces it doesn't but it
it deals with the entire issue in a very
uh offhanded shallow way and I think if
it were strictly about that in a more
one-to-one fashion that would be a
bigger problem than the degree to which
it currently exists where at least to me
it feels more like an offshoot of not
thinking through the implications of
what he was doing which is not okay but
I think it's the difference between
accidentally stumbling into
um problematic story elements and
placing them there deliberately and then
failing to do anything with them
if that makes sense
views on the news that Wizards Wizards
Hasbro new open gaming license I had
wondered if anyone was going to ask this
and actually technically I shouldn't be
answering this because it was put in
after the stream started I'm gonna touch
on it real quick
um we're running late and I apologize
but uh
it's [ __ ]
if people don't know
uh Wizards of the Coast now owned by
Hasbro which owns
Dungeons and Dragons that brand and that
system
they are changing their opening license
agreement which basically basically what
they're doing the short dirty lacking
nuanced version
is that
they are claiming ownership
of any original
um
story told using their product
so all the DND streams
all of those things they are claiming
ownership of that unless you negotiate
a specific licensing agreement with them
so
this is not unheard of it's wow I'll
backtrack I think it's unheard of in
tabletop gaming it's not unheard of in
general Nintendo did their version of
this a while back when they said that
they would
um do
um
uh dmca takedowns of any Let's Plays of
any of their video games unless the
person had signed up for a program with
Nintendo that gave Nintendo a cut
similarly blizzard when they did their
update they're reforging of
um
Warcraft 3 they updated the user
agreement so that anything created using
the assets of their map editor or
anything like that they owned and the
reason they did that was because uh
mobas were created with their engine and
they never owned a piece of that
and every time this has happened it has
bit them in the ass and it's going to
bite Wizards of the Coast in the ass and
one of two things is going to happen
either the outcry is going to be so huge
that they realize that if they stick to
their guns on this
that so many people will abandon the
system for something else
that it will not only permanently
completely screw their community
and people will just be bitterly leaving
either it'll do that or just like they
just won't have the customer base they
used to
um
and that and if they realize that before
they fully pull the trigger on it that
means that they'll back off
or they'll plow ahead and they'll just
and they'll just eat that loss and it
will be a loss it's going to be a big
loss like the d d stream that I'm on
right now we're talking behind the
scenes about switching the system
we're level 11 characters we've been
we've been doing the story for over a
year
and we're talking about
continuing the same story
but changing the system
because that's how messed up this is
so
yeah
yeah whole thing whole thing's a mess
all right I got some more Super chats to
do and then I'm probably gonna wrap it
up because there were a lot of questions
in the in the Discord tonight a lot a
lot all right
Dharma thank you very much for re-upping
your membership much love to the council
and Senpai thank you very much uh
Supreme Omega thank you happy 2023 in
contrast to the new 52 post crisis
seemed
um more of a success in spite of some
continuity issues is it because they
planned it better no they didn't plan it
well at all
no
post-crisis was a mess there were
multiple
um
writers who who have gone on record
since then like we did not know what was
Canon for about a year we didn't know
what we could use and then we would get
an editorial mandate saying hey what are
you doing you're like you didn't tell us
what we could do so no it was not well
planned I think the um
the big difference was that it was
something that at least a chunk of the
uh fans had been asking for
I think that the story used to kick it
off was better received so I think that
helped and I think that
the choices made in post-crisis felt a
lot more like let's take things in a
bold New Direction than let's flatten
everything and make it all seem the same
and do 50 freaking Batman books like
there's so much about the two that isn't
comparable
um
that just new 52 is just crap it just is
supreme Omega back again on 90 Spidey
thoughts on Venom and Carnage I enjoyed
them at the time both were overused
severely
um Venom especially they they really
milked him to death I did enjoy them at
the time though I won't lie you know
back when I was 12. John vinyls back
again regarding artists uh people still
do love Roald Dahl's work even though he
was a massively racist anti-semite that
is true he's also dead
so he can't do any more harm and that's
not to say that like the degree to which
those ideas are infused in his books
isn't harmless it still might be if you
are not prepared to talk through and
acknowledge those problems but like
dude can't do any more damage than he's
already done so it's not really
equivocal if you're going to compare
that to you know Harry Potter stuff
that having been said
uh I get unnerved lately how quickly
people are jumping to the idea of you
can't separate the artist from the art
unless the artist is dead first of all I
would argue even then you still really
can't and fully shouldn't but I'm seeing
that become a go-to point and it makes
me uncomfortable
yeah I'm just gonna say that put it on
the record like to a degree that like
somebody actually very flatly
um
in a response to a tweet I did once
implied that somebody should unalive JK
Rowling
yeah maybe having seen that happen in a
reply to my tweet is why I'm
uncomfortable with how frequently I'm
seeing that I don't know
foreign
gonna try and wrap this up what are your
thoughts on liking older problematic
works I think I don't think there's
anything inherently long wrong with
liking it as long as you're not
defending it I mean if you because like
as long as you know what the problems
are and you're not pushing it over on
anyone else and you're not encouraging
other people to ignore the problematic
elements I don't think that there's an
inherent problem with liking that stuff
there's problematic stuff I like some of
my favorite stuff is problematic
but if you're willing to just grapple
with the things wrong with it and not
deny them not pretend they aren't there
or not argue with people to say yeah but
this about it and just go no I know but
you know it means a lot to me like I can
respect that
let's say
do I have high cheekbones I have no idea
I don't know what qualifies as high
cheekbones
uh also the biggest competitor to DND
Pathfinder was created with the ogl yeah
that's kind of my point this is going to
damage the competition in the table at
the top RPG space plus the businesses
that exist making third-party content
for d d well
anything like Pathfinder once um
if if Dungeons and Dragons and Wizards
of the Coast go through this change
there's going to be some massive Court
battles
because you know you know some of the
stuff that has been done officially
licensed through
D like Lord of the Rings has a D and D
extension is Wizard of the coast gonna
try and claim Lord of the Rings now like
probably not but like there's gonna be
lawsuits
there's going to be big lawsuits if this
goes through
uh okay
I see somebody's gotten into a
discussion about wokeness I don't have
the spoons I'm skipping it
Warhol was mentioned earlier David Bowie
plays Andy Warhol in the biopic of Gene
uh oh sorry Jean-Michel Basquiat
and just add uh who reference and Derek
Jacoby plays Francis Bacon in a biopake
okay
do I have a nickname for my fan base I
don't
I should by now I've been doing this
long enough but now I don't
imagine if JK Rowling wrote an episode
of Doctor Who she got enough red she and
freaking Harry Potter got enough
references in that show it's bad enough
as is supreme Omega okay we we got we
got uh we gotta wrap it up
um Sabrina Omega also on the new 52
[Music]
um
do you another issue do you think
another issue with it is that Jim Lee
hired his buddies at Marvel like Rob
life out because New 52 feels Ultra 90s
Marvel image I mean it didn't help
I mean and that was part of what new 52
did it didn't just
um end existing stories it scrapped the
creative team Jim Lee like redesigned
all the characters himself so there was
uh there was a uniformity I think they
were thinking well it's better
continuity it's visually coherent yeah
it's boring they all because they're all
designed by the same freaking guy yeah
no that like the the new 52 was just
crap it was just crap
um yeah I know like my my clothes out
like you are the council and you are but
like I think I think the question was a
bit more like because you know
um it's usually more in the in the
openings because you have folks like um
uh Dominic Knowles like hello my
beautiful Watchers or what have you I
don't have something uh along that lines
because it uh
I guess if I were just open by saying
greetings to the council I suppose I
could
I guess it's just as well I don't have a
name I don't have a uh any kind of
cutesy name for my fan base because I
think it would feel awkward to open with
I already feel awkward enough coming up
with my random nonsense gags anyways I
need to stop I need to stop it's 8 20.
we've gone long
all right
all right council's in session I used to
say that melting penguins like
10 years ago
thank you everybody for joining me thank
you for your time thank you for your
questions thank you for your super chats
and
um thank you for your patience
so tomorrow uh tomorrow morning 10 30 uh
a.m Eastern Standard time I will be on
Twitch probably finishing up lost ruins
I expect I'm probably gonna hit the end
of that game uh also uh tomorrow on the
main channel will be the latest latest
episode of take two Doctor Who review
and that will be on praxius
and then Friday again on Twitch I will
be streaming and on Saturday on the main
Channel
uh I will be talking about
uh
it's hard to explain what I'll be
talking about I'll be doing a bit of
introspection how about that let's go
with that for now I'll tease you with
that
so thank you everybody for joining me
have a wonderful night
and uh
have a good New Year
and please remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings
and until next time this Council
is adjourned
mccavity